et ce soir à 20h30 et bien vous pourrez
suivre une nouvelle série en six
épisodes dont vous pourrez soit suivre
le premier épisode ce soir à 20h30 et le
2e demain soir s'appelle
blanc-bleu-rouge pourquoi bien parce que
blanc symbolise les chouans la monarchie
le bleu les républicains et le rouge le
sang versé pendant cette longue guerre
civile qui durera six ans et fit plus de
cinq cent mille morts blanc bleu rouge
est une série adaptée par claude brûlé
d'après le roman de françoise linares
sophie mon coeur est réalisé par yannick
andrei c'est une histoire d'amour
difficile entre un chou ans et une jeune
bourgeoise libéral le chouan est
interprété par bernard giraudeau aux
côtés de anne canovas donc ce soir ne
manquez pas le premier épisode et demain
soir le deuxième blanc bleu rouge
ensuite à 21 heures 30 ce soir eh bien
nous avons rendez vous avec le livre
avec l'émission littéraire de georges
suffert la rage de lire qui a pour thème
la révolution du livre en format de
poche 1980 est l'année internationale
des handicapés et tf1 nous propose
chaque mercredi à 13h40
une émission qui est le relais qui leur
est consacré portes ouvertes magazine de
claude rubin et de bénédicte la place et
je voudrais vous signaler dès maintenant
que les dialogues de cette émission
seront sous-titrés et puis ensuite à
partir de 13h55 bien nos jeunes amis
retrouveront les visiteurs du mercredi
l'émission de christophe izard mais
c'est une version 1981 donc ne la
manquez pas ne manquez pas cette premier
rendez-vous de 1980 les visiteurs du
mercredi tout à l'heure donc à 13h55
dans un instant les actualités en
compagnie de jean pierre pernaut et
marie laure augry
où